Just flag a lot of people out here.
Just get him degrees by luck or by cheating your way through if that was the
case in college is so accessible.
I just feel like we'll have a lot of one of these.
Okay.
Come on.
College grads on that side.
And why dropouts on the other side?
First statement,
I feared how I would be judged if I didn't go to college.
Just me and then that's cool.
It was the fear of me,
people with thought,
um,
as far as like my peers.
But then when you start bringing your parents into it and it's like that's a
greater fear.
It's like you live with your parents.
It's like,
you know,
you want to make them proud.
So I just fear this closure between me and my parents,
you know?
Yeah I am Shawn Fitzpatrick.
I went to Columbia,
Chicago for not even a semester and I was like,
no,
you know what,
let's go back to California and do music.
I went because they wanted me to go and then,
and then I said,
if you want me to make you proud,
uh,
let me do this.
Non Agree or it's come on in.
I wasn't afraid that I would be judged if I didn't go to college,
but I also didn't question going to college.
It was just kind of the next step and I didn't plan otherwise.
So that's what that path of growth,
it seemed like it was the next step.
Yeah.
And you're encouraged by your parents and
they gave me that pathway of saying,
you know,
the only way you're going to succeed is through college.
But then as I got older,
they gave me the idea,
well,
you can do whatever you want.
If you find your path though,
you need to find your path.
But if you count,
you should go to college.
At the end of the day,
I believe college should be free.
I'm broke.
I had an instate,
like all of my tuition was paid for and I still have debt now I'm sitting on it
and I don't have a job.
Not like a real job.
I,
the dad definitely racks up.
It's ridiculous.
That's true.
But that that becomes an investment in the future at the end of the day.
So you have to take that on
education.
But does your like was actually one degree or a higher paying job?
Not In my experience it's necessary.
I didn't even question going to college until after I had finished.
It was like,
what do I do now and why did I even go?
And you know,
if everyone went to college it would become useless
just for like a lot of people out here just get them degrees by luck or getting
degrees by cheating your way through.
And if that was the case in college is so accessible,
I just feel like we'll have a lot of wannabes and that people were really
passionate about,
you know,
what they want to do or dedicating sweat bones and tears into what they're
doing.
So the world would,
I don't think we'll be a better place if everyone was just a degree.
Okay.
Converted at seems very my cause if,
yeah,
I guess then you don't think of it in our college.
You're just doing it.
You just think about labor workers,
like people that just do manual labor.
You don't need a degree to do some manual labor work.
So if you have everyone,
you know,
sticking their heads in a book,
we won't have stuff being built.
Your House won't be billed yard,
your cars won't be fixed.
You're all changed.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you have to realize that in life,
especially in the world,
it's a balance of,
yeah.
Fifth people,
like
I come from a minority,
underrepresented,
uh,
disenfranchised.
And in my college experience,
I,
the higher I got,
the less people that look like me that I saw.
So the more people that look like me in college would make me so happy.
That's what I'm saying.
So like,
it's tremendous to see more people going to college,
but you have to realize that this is,
if yes,
what are people don't want to,
oh no,
no,
no.
But if more people did,
then it would be a good thing.
That's right.
I just think that college education,
if everyone had it,
I don't think it would make the degree itself useless.
Yeah,
I think that's the one part.
Oh No,
I'm,
I think we were taking off a pedestal,
not making it meaningless.
Okay.
I know what I want to do with my life.
Yes.
Um,
I'm still figuring it out,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm in it right now,
so I feel like,
I know,
but there's so much more that's getting revealed as soon as I find out I'm,
I'm currently getting a degree in psychotherapy,
however,
I still need two or three more years to get all my hours.
And so I'm debating whether or not even to get my license and just be on a woman
empowerment coach.
And other than getting it done with Grad School,
I can fully invested my,
all of myself into it.
So
yeah,
it took a minute.
I mean,
yeah,
it was not an easy journey and it was a lot of investing and finding out that I
was investing in the wrong things.
So,
you know,
I like how you changed your mind.
Bought a hot house like we,
I really don't know.
Do I?
I want to say that I'm,
I don't feel lost.
Like,
I don't feel like,
oh,
I don't want to do,
I don't know what I want to do with my life.
I'm actively pursuing a lot of goals right now and I don't anticipate like one
goal last time.
You like time.
Exactly.
You Go,
I know all the things that I want to do.
I'm just not sure which one is the like for you guys it's like this is it.
For me.
I was like,
I'm,
I'm dibble and dabble in some different things.
I'm just like,
anything could be the final goal.
I just don't know which one it is.
I want to perfect every craft that was going to school for architecture.
And I was,
uh,
three years in and then I got into acting and I both,
the job when I realized,
I was like,
Whoa,
I really like doing this.
So dropped out of school and I decided that I'd pursue acting instead.
But that came later on after I did three years of college and I did four.
I have three classes before I graduated.
I just like,
I decided to leave because I felt the time for me to pursue the things I wanted
to do.
My life was now in college was holding me back from that.
Okay.
Education is the key to success.
So when I heard education,
um,
you know,
I didn't necessarily associated with college.
Yeah.
I just associated with gathering all the tools and the data and the knowledge
and,
and then embodying that into whatever field you want to be successful.
And the success too.
It doesn't just come with luck.
You know,
you have to,
you have to work harder when you want to do.
And what success
I took,
education has like a college degree.
When you presented that question,
I thought that's why I didn't even walk up because,
and we got to realize like we learn daily.
Like every day we're learning something and it's so funny.
There's no book in front of us to learn those things.
I will learn.
It just so happened that we crossed the right person or someone related that
information to us or you know,
just based off life experiences.
So I don't think that you're going to be successful based on the fact that you
went to school or you're know you're opening up a book or something daily.
It's a learning experience.
Every time you wake up in the morning,
you should be learning something new.
At the end of the day.
That's how I feel about life.
So we're actually more so on the same page,
different parts of it.
[inaudible]
that's a wrap guys.
Hey guys,
this is Dan and this is Jason,
and you're just watching another episode of middle ground.
Thank you so much.
Please let us know in the comments below,
which person's opinion resonated the most with you.
We'd love to hear from you.
So anyway,
and get involve,
commenting,
liking,
subscribing,
sharing with your friends.
We really appreciate it.
It all helps see you later.
Okay.